but what really matters is that YouTube
has given me a business model it
basically runs in my sleep it's like a
silent salesperson for me putting
bookings on my calendar I want every V
student every thick media podcast
listener to listen to Jen and learn from
Jen because the Creator needs to learn
from the business owner to think
different your Channel's not even
monetized but you've got a sixf fig
business so how can you get more leads
clients and sales for your business
using YouTube why should business owners
pay attention to YouTube and do you
ultimately need millions of subscribers
to actually grow your business and make
more income and more impact this is
going to be a powerful episode because
our guest today is Jen devor RoR who is
a former marketing executive for the
NASA at the Kennedy Space Center turned
entrepreneur she owns a magazine
publishing company and serves as a
spokesperson on YouTube's number one
channel for magazine publishing a little
bit later in the episode she's also
going to be breaking down how we can
Outsource our marketing she's got a
brand new book out and how to reach more
people scale faster and work less she'll
be talking about some red flags to look
uh watch out for when signing up for
Outsource marketing services and really
her six steps so this is going to be a
powerp packed episode of the think media
podcast so buckle your seat belt because
as a result of listening to this episode
really believe you'll be able to grow
your business further faster and make a
greater difference with your products
and services but Jen welcome to the
think media podcast Sean thanks for
having me I'm I'm so grateful to you and
to the think media team for everything
that I've learned in video ranking
Academy that has brought me to this
moment yeah and we're inspired by all
the action you've taken and um
everything you're doing and I want to
kind of dive in first let's just talk
about YouTube high level you're a
professional um you've done a lot of
cool things in your career and you're
not a a YouTuber you probably wouldn't
call yourself that so you're approaching
YouTube with this entrepreneur mindset
Why YouTube why did you want to start a
YouTube channel in the first place and
uh pick this platform I started on
YouTube in
2020 when lockdowns hit because prior to
that I was generating most of my
business as a professional speaker
speaking on other people's stages at
conferences and then when Downs hit and
Live Events got cancelled I needed to
scramble truthfully and figure out a
different way to get in front of people
I like to sell one to many type of
marketing I don't you know I'm not like
much of a networker I don't like cold
calling and one of my friends my one of
my speaker friends Roger Wakefield who
I'm sure you know um is a famous plumber
on YouTube and we were talking one day
and and he he and I had met through the
speaking circuit and he said why don't
you just go go to YouTube Jen you just
you need to be there I had tried YouTube
in the past but I didn't know what I was
doing I was using it basically as a
portfolio for my speaking demos and so I
listened to Roger I joined your program
and that's how I got into YouTube was
basically out of necessity needing to
get in front of a lot of people and
needing to share my message so that I
could grow my business and tell us a
little bit about your business this was
your magazine Publishing Company correct
yeah so I have two businesses I have I
work as a what I call outsourced CMO
Chief marketing officer I have a handful
of clients on a retainer with me and I
manage their manage their online
marketing for them and then I also have
a magazine publishing company that came
about because of YouTube when I first
started my channel I was doing a mix of
videos probably had like three or four
topics a lot of them were about sales
funnels getting traffic um landing pages
email marketing and then I had also
developed my own magazine as a like
basically as a marketing tool for myself
as a speaker so I was kind of like my
content was like three or four topics
but the magazine videos started to pop
off and then as you say in V it's like
once you see what's working double down
and so that's what I did and I just
started Double Down doubling down on the
magazine publishing videos because there
was no competition really to speak of
there was some older videos or some
videos that weren't really about how to
use a magazine to P to like grow your
business and so I have I have the
marketing company where I work as a CMO
for a handful of clients and then um
coaching on the side too and then the
magazine publishing company is a
separate business now thanks to YouTube
with its own dedign designated business
manager its own Tech and design team and
everything wow and I'll never forget um
a story because you emailed us and you
just said hey yeah um I just had my
first ever
$11,000 week so
$111,000 of business Revenue in a
one-week period that I believe was for
the magazine company correct correct yep
because you had YouTube videos out there
with some call to action that then was
able to lead to that business that came
in but I've taken a screenshot and told
this story many times because if I
remember you had exactly 546
subscribers at the time of or right
around there when you emailed us and so
it's one of my favorite stories and I
did not even know that actually YouTube
Led even to the formulation of a new
product and business I think that's an
interesting opportunity for our
listeners um you know Market your
existing products and services but what
maybe new are people demanding and or
asking for that you could um you know
potentially create so such a it's a
$111,000 a business a big number for
such a small subscriber count and so
it's very inspiring uh tell us a little
bit about that story and was it one
breakout video was it a couple of videos
what happened when uh that business came
in basically one day I logged into my
vid IQ account and saw that some of
these magazine videos were ranking
number one in the search terms and so
even though the channel was small less
than a thousand subscribers the video
were ranking and they're still there
they were ranking top in YouTube search
for magazine self-publishing in
particular and so I knew I was on to
something with the traffic because
traffic is a major problem for a lot of
entrepreneur probably all everybody and
so I saw the potential with the traffic
but I'm also a Russell Brunson Dan
Kennedy fan and I've been studying their
work and following their model for a
long time and I realized that having the
traffic wasn't going to convert into
leads so how would I harness the traffic
and then convert it into actual business
so I built a funnel a super simple
Russell Brunson perfect webinar funnel
and I started linking the funnel in the
description of all of the videos and
then putting it in the link of the
banner and then I created a promo video
for the webinar on the channel and that
was when it really started taking off
and I coined the term uh magazine funnel
and then Russell even in had me on the
clickfunnels radio Podcast because of
the the magazine funnel so I got more
traffic and more attention from that Dan
Kennedy had me on the magnetic marketing
podcast and it really just took took off
because I wasn't looking at it just as
YouTube videos I was looking at it as
traffic to a funnel and so I decided and
scrambled and created this magazine
I called the the concept the magazine
funnel um which is it's not just a
magazine that we create for clients but
it's a magazine and a sales funnel
combined and but me having my own
webinar funnel to promote the concept of
a magazine funnel and then it's a
two-page webinar that moves people to a
thank you page that has my calendar on
it and people sign up for a call I talk
to them and land business that way and
so the whole entire business model
started from that wow and so
even one of the things that was
interesting too is you had already made
videos with which you had not actually
given a call to action in correct but as
you saw go to my website kind of you
know like just yeah but kind of a nugget
there is actually perhaps looking at
videos in your past Library if you're
established at any level if you've been
posting videos you're listening to this
can you update your pinned comment can
you update links in your description we
would tell you to make sure that it's
above the fold meaning it's the top
three lines because if someone's
interested in the topic um and they
check the description and that link they
see it's clickable then you could send
them into um anywhere you want updating
your cover image with a URL so that they
could jump into this and and then
ultimately creating a sales process
because you move the conversation off of
YouTube to a webinar to a web class to a
phone call so that they could talk to
you and to land business and so
ultimately um leading to leads and then
clients and and sales and so that's so
powerful and so inspiring now have you
continued to double down since then uh
your YouTube strategy are you using your
channel to promote your three businesses
um or and kind of talking about all
things there what what's kind of
happened since then on your YouTube
channel what have you been learning I
think I got this advice from your team
also where I doubled down and I just
stayed the course so this is over three
years now and I've published a weekly
video for over three years I maybe have
missed three weeks out of those three
years I've been super consistent and I
have tons of videos on magazine
publishing and since I'm still secure in
the top rank for magazine publishing on
search engine now I've started to
broaden it back up a little bit
especially because I have the new book
broaden it back out a little bit still
related to marketing um and media and
start to integrate more content related
to like marketing productivity because
it's all related all my magazine
Publishers all my magazine publishing
clients still need marketing they still
need to know um so that's how it's been
helping me with those with those two
divisions of the business is magazine
publishing I still keep going but I'm
starting to slowly broaden the channel
back up a little bit and create that
more like marketing product it content
well at the at the same time not not
letting off of magazines but starting to
add another topic even and and making
sure that they're still related so yes
so now they're starting to because I
have more subscribers now I have 2,590
subscribers now it's starting to work
for both and then also I have to say the
just having the content for the
marketing side of the business and me
just sharing it with my email list I
send a I send an email out to my list
every week that has the video of the
week in it and that has helped me drive
business for the marketing side of my
company and then also social media
promotion and now just people kind of
know that I've got this YouTube channel
and they're just starting to pay
attention and tune in and so yeah all
both of the divisions of the business
are growing because of that that's
amazing now how are you making videos
for some many business owners the tech
hurdle
the production workflow and then all the
way down to making great thumbnails and
your thumbnails are especially have
evolved and they're really good so all
these different YouTube best practices
for you what are some of the tips in
terms of your workflow and how you
create content and edit have you
delegated some of that um do you keep it
simple not even edit like what has been
your workflow maybe how's it evolved and
what is it now I first started on my
iPhone
um I basically just had a desk with a
chair a ring light and an iPhone on a
selfie stand and I started making videos
and I didn't even have a professional
microphone nothing I will say that I do
have a little bit of an unfair advantage
in that I have worked in television I've
worked I've studied broadcasting in high
school I've worked at two TV stations
and so I kind of know how video works
just from a production standpoint I also
was a certified professional
photographer for seven years so I know
what you know great composition and
lighting looks like I think that does
give me a little bit of an an unfair
Advantage but really I first started
just on my you um on my iPhone with
little to no editing but because the
goal is to get 1% better with every
video I've definitely evolved over the
last three years and so my set continues
to evolve my lighting um I've upgraded
to a Canon DSLR camera that's just
because that's what I learned I learned
how to shoot photography on Canon
cameras so I'm just kind of used to them
um so I now shoot on a Canon camera I do
edit them a lot now they're probably not
ased like as edited as some YouTubers
but I definitely am putting a lot into
the editing and I have been editing my
own videos for the last while um but I
do have a team now I do have a video
video editor that can he can pitch in
for me when I'm going to go on vacation
or I'm too busy
or uh you know just don't want to do it
I just still haven't 100% given complete
control over my own YouTube uh videos
but I do have my editor uh take the
short videos out so like the less than
60 second verticals out and he you know
I give him the timestamp and he edits
those out and creates the repurpose
content for me as well but then I also
have my team I have a specific thumbnail
designer who that's all he does is all
my thumbnails now I used to do them
myself in canva and I realized oh my
gosh I don't know what I'm doing like
this that is like the first thing you
should Outsource is your thumbnails so I
I have a a dedicated thumbnail designer
I have my video editor who can repurpose
content and then step in for me when I'm
not you know too busy or on vacation or
whatever and I don't want to edit my
videos and then I do have um a project
manager and graphic designers and email
marketers and all this like all these um
other people that help with the
marketing of the content as well your
story is inspiring because I love that
you're mentioning a key word and that's
three years and so there's been an
evolution 1% better with every upload
and the adding on now of systems and
team and Outsourcing to support uh your
overall workflow and your overall
business and you're an expert at that
and the author of Outsource your
marketing and so in just a second we I
want to dive into your new book and and
these six principles and some of the
things we can learn because especially
as business owners and in our community
we have business-minded content creators
as well uh man we we have to delegate
I've heard it said delegate or die at
some point you um you can't carry it all
yourself and so I'm excited to learn
this from you but I want to encourage uh
everybody listening a couple things one
um Jen has been talking about video raet
Academy that was the program she's a
part of today's episode is brought to
you by VR podcast.com if you actually
want to look at just a special offer on
video ret Academy just for thi media
podcast listeners you could always go to
vodcast outcom that'll be in the show
notes I also want to point you to um
Jen's new book which is called Outsource
your marketing and that we're about to
talk about that but she's also got some
free resources that you could check out
and um the book is out on Amazon as well
and you can check out her Channel um and
before we get into the Outsource stuff
one of your videos piqued my
curiosity AI head shots for $10 and you
compared suited up versus try it on um
seemed very cool I was wondering is
suited up a way to like try on clothes
you don't even own what what are these
AI headshot softwares and I think for
people that are maybe wanting to have a
great you're a you know Pro photographer
you've got an incredible YouTube Avatar
a nice head shot and you're doing the
magazine thing so you've got all of that
understanding but I think a lot of
people could improve their Avatar their
social media head shot and they might
have low Tech equipment are these cool
softwares what do they do yeah they're
awesome I've just really been
experimenting with the artificial
intelligence software programs I in
particular the things that can help us
be better creators and better marketers
and yeah suup is a a really cool AI
website that allows you to upload like
10 of your selfie 10 or 15 of your
selfies you upload it into their website
and then it will um generate for you
professional head shot that look like
you have gone through a bunch of
locations with your photographer put on
a lot of different outfits for your
photo shoot and just really cool and I
just really did those videos as just
some fun content for the YouTube channel
they really took off they've got like
there they've got some awesome views on
on those on those uh pieces of content
as well but I really just did them just
because I was curious what was going on
with AI from a marketing perspective and
I was like well if I'm gonna go try this
out I might as well make a video out of
it and but yeah they're they're great
tools for Content creators so the apps
are suit up and then try it on and it is
funny because I I mean you don't you're
telling me in the thumbnail there's a
picture of you with a leather jacket do
you not own that leather jacket no I did
not have those those outfits on at all
that was what was so cool about it man
so definitely we'll we'll link up of
these in the uh show notes as well
before we dive into the Outsource stuff
it on just the list or the topic of AI
software is there any AI you're using
for anything at all that you love right
now and how are you using it I'm using
some of the AI in canva like the
built-in software that's inside of the
inside canva um also my friend Austin
Armstrong created a a software program
an artificial intelligence program
called syllabi which is really cool
really great great for Content creators
if you're struggling with writing your
video scripts and then turning your
video scripts into blog posts syllabi is
awesome and and then I'm just kind of
and then I'm just you know still using
chat
GPT um but I'm not really using AI as
much right now to come up with my video
ideas I do use the AI tools inside of
vid IQ to research and kind of just
check my hunch on if my video topics are
going to be great and I did use the AI
inside of vid IQ to do a channel review
which was really helpful I think that
would be a task that should be put on a
Content Creator's calendar on a regular
basis is to to do a channel review with
vid IQ that is a great point and that
you're referencing um their AI coach
which is not only recently launched but
just continues to evolve it's a very
powerful tool and uh vid IQ is not
officially sponsoring this video but
they are one of our sponsors that we
consistently work with and we just love
uh them we actually recently was talking
to Rob Sandy who's the founder of vid IQ
at VidCon and just so many cool things
on the horizon so um great tools and
we'll this is one of those episodes to
definitely check out the show notes and
some of the resources because we're
covering a lot of territory here but I
cannot wait to dive into Outsource your
marketing I know that we have business
owners listening to this episode and and
they're maybe already in the mindset of
building a team maybe from day one they
started to think about needing to
delegate um and kind of came into it
from another approach but then
especially on our content creator side
and I know I can empathize with this
because I'm kind of like an accidental
entrepreneur I started making videos in
my bedroom and then was like man how do
I turn this into a company and then as
you're also bootstrapping your way up
finances can be tough like you're making
some money but is it you're like I can't
hire somebody for $65,000 a year
healthare and all this you know um or
whatever so um when it comes to
Outsourcing there's so many nuggets here
that we can learn give us a little
overview of your book though and maybe
how your experience in Outsourcing and
why it matters why this is a big deal
and why this book yeah so gosh I feel
like this book is like a 20-year project
that's just been it's like a culmination
of all of my experience when I worked at
Nasa I managed their all their advert
paid advertising programs television
radio Billboards print collat collateral
everything and so my responsibility was
to manage the agency so that gave me the
inside scoop on how agencies work and
then when I decided to become an
entrepreneur the first company that I
created was a photography studio had
that for seven years um but then the the
second business after that was another
was an agency I started my own agency
with two business partners which still
exists to this day
uh it's very successful and we had so I
had two business partners big fancy
office couple of employees on staff and
one of the mistakes that I made for my
own self for my own life with that
business model was you know kind of like
being tied to the office being tied to
the employees being tied to the business
partners and I I really wanted more of a
a lifestyle type of business where I
could work from anywhere and not
necessarily be responsible for full-time
employees on the payroll and so um now
with this business model that I have now
over the last four years I have just
started building a team of everyone from
Freelancers to Virtual assistants even
coaches I consider part of my team the
people that I trust and hire to share
knowledge with me um and my project
manager is a part part of my team and I
started to realize that all this
experience of working with agencies
having employees finding and keeping
virtual assistants project managers that
want to stay with me for the long term
most my project manager um I've known
her for years and my virtual assistants
and my tech team and my Freelancers have
all been with me since the beginning
like three years and so I just and when
I started working with my clients I
started realizing that one of the major
problems they were having was that they
they didn't really know what to look for
when they were recruiting people onto
their outsourc team and also they didn't
know how to delegate with to them they
didn't know how to communicate their
expectations they didn't know how to
share what they were trying to do and
what they like and what they don't like
and so a lot of my clients this is why I
work as an Outsource CMO is because a
lot of my clients when they were coming
to me they were sharing this pain they
were like oh I hired this social social
media manager and she doesn't know what
she's doing and I'm I'm like well what
did you tell her what's the input how
are you communicating what you're what
you want from them what your style is
what your goals are because a lot of
times the breakdown in delegation is is
the wrong communication not being able
to speak the language of Freelancers and
so this book basically is my S I had to
think about what is the if I was
teaching what I do and how I hire
awesome people to clients or prospects
or you know even that don't even want to
hire me but just I want to put this
knowledge into a book what would the
process be in a way that I could teach
it and so that's that's what the book is
about I want to invite you guys to our
YouTube 1K challenge you can join this
challenge for free as we show you how to
grow your first 1,000 subscribers and
make your first $1,000 on YouTube we've
had countless people join us during this
1K challenge who are now at 1,000
subscribers and past 1,000 subscribers
making money on YouTube and you could be
the next person if you just go to 21k
challenge.com you can sign up for the
very next challenge and we can't wait to
see you guys there that's so cool and
it's specifically called Outsource your
marketing with that specialty of
focusing on getting your marketing going
it's for Founders and CEOs that want to
scale their business but don't want to
hire an over bloated Ad Agency so we've
had some of our own experience with that
and AD Ad Agency fees going up and up
and up and up um and so also business
owners who want marketing services but
want to save time and money or
entrepreneurs that want to make better
decisions when hiring marketing
Freelancers so so much is in here and of
course people can check out the book and
I think this is a must pickup because
this is one of those an advantages that
just many many get stuck here it's a
It's A Hard Road it's it's a hard skill
to learn and so investing in learning
but before we get into these six things
you built a framework there's some red
flags to watch out for uh when it comes
to like maybe signing up for marketing
services in general what are maybe some
of the mistakes Red Flags uh business
owners that have you know hired an
agency they're disappointed they're not
looking under the hood I don't know you
you tell me what are some red flags to
help out some of the business owners
listening the biggest one I see is that
the agencies want this is a secret
agencies want you to stick with them and
they will create your marketing on
platforms that only they have access to
or you're leasing a spot on their
account
or you're even leasing your website from
them and so as soon as you decide this
agency isn't really working for me
anymore and you might want to go your
separate ways when you go to end your
contract you lose everything it's not
it's not being built for you as work for
hire and so you really want to look at
your contracts and make sure that
everything that the agency is going to
do for you is for you on your platforms
in addition to that make sure that you
have administrative control of your
accounts this is shocking to me how many
business owners have no idea how to even
log into their website or what the
administrative password is to their
YouTube channel or their email list and
that's a big red flag if you're hiring a
company and they don't want to release
those things to you or they want to
build everything on a platform and just
like license a seat to you you don't
want to do that man so good advice and
you've got a six-part framework this is
in the book so I figured maybe we just
sue a 30,000 foot level on here strategy
systems team tactics results and mindset
what do we start on here where does it
start with the
mindset yeah it does and I put it I put
the system in a circle because it's
never ending it's like it depends on
where you're at right so okay but let's
just let's pick mindset as the as
chapter one first you have to have the
mindset that marketing is important and
I say take it to the point that it's you
see yourself as not just a provider of
your services but you see yourself as a
marketer of your services I consider
myself I put it on my profiles I put it
in my bio I'm the spokes person of my
company that's how important it is that
has been the key to the fast success
especially of the magazine publishing
company which basically happened
overnight that has that was the mindset
that that I had was I'm not going to get
stuck working in the business and I'm
not going
to um relegate marketing to a task that
just has to be done it needs to be the
top priority so that's first off mindset
you know I love that I I heard a friend
of mine say it this way they said that
you know business owners they fall in
love with their product and their
service as they should and they want
they want customers and Prospects to get
their product and their service and
that's all they want to do though and um
one of the biggest
mistakes that business owners make is
they don't date Sam and for those that
are you know listening to this they
might be like date Sam like I already
I'm already dating somebody I'm not
gonna date somebody else or they're like
I'm married that sounds sketchy I don't
know but no matter I don't care if
you've been married 17 years like me you
still need to you actually don't need to
just date Sam you need to marry Sam
who's Sam Sam is sales and
marketing and two things that we a lot
of times we it's we don't love sales and
marketing we love the main thing we do
and how we help people we don't love
sales and marketing we love the way we
serve people we want them to get our
products and services but it is your
ethical responsibility it is your duty
it is your primary responsibility as the
founder to actually be obsessed with
ethical sales and marketing so that you
could get your products and services
into the hands of as many people as
possible and your company is a sales and
marketing company of your services I'm
just echoing you now your your that your
job
is to make sure that Sam is at the
center of of course also the thing you
do and being obsessed with the marketing
and the sales of the thing you do and
it's a big mindset shift and so uh you
know I know we have many audio listeners
and you can't comment it means the world
to us though if you can rate and review
the podcast wherever you listen but if
you're on YouTube let me know are you
committed to starting to uh date Sam or
Mary Sam um and tell us in the comments
and leaning into sales and marketing
with that mind set well what's next on
the framework the mistake that a lot of
business owners make when they start to
Outsource their marketing is they jump
on tactics well oh now I need to be on
Instagram or now I need to be making Tik
Tok videos and they're not thinking
through the full strategy of where is it
going to lead like I shared earlier
YouTube to me is the traffic that leads
to the funnel it's a strategy and I'm
thinking how am I going to take this
traffic off of YouTube move them on to
to the next step in the buyer Journey
with me and then how I'm how am I going
to sell I sell on zoom and then what are
my offers that whole entire strategy
just for the YouTube channel was thought
through before I started um building out
the system or learning about systems and
building the team so brilliant and uh
man I think it was Sun Su who said that
uh uh tactics without strategy
is the noise before defeat that if all
we're doing is out there with some
tactical thing even if you got a viral
Tik Tok so what even if you got a viral
YouTube short so what if it's not
connected to a bigger strategy even if
you made the best thumbnail in the world
um and uh we get obsessed with the
tactics though we want the we want the
the little gimmicks and it makes me
think that that's sometimes sometimes uh
even ad agencies this could be a red
flag of them as well marketing agencies
because they're they're feeding you
information and they might like look at
what we just accomplished look at all
these Impressions or all this reach but
the question is unto what and are they
also if they're not informing your
strategy probably why you need to take
your personal power back and follow Jen
and and follow what she's prescribing
here but to make sure that your strategy
Rock Solid because just like oh we grew
your Instagram account who cares like oh
we got a few more what does even YouTube
views even YouTube subscribers but how
does it connect to the overall strategy
man that's a chapter to dive deeper in
but what's next systems for YouTubers or
content creators video content creators
um what systems do you need so do you
need vid IQ do you need do you need to
learn a system that's what brought me to
VRA was I okay I knew that YouTube was
going to be my new strategy versus
speaking on stages so what is the system
of YouTube what do I need to know um
before I start running and spending a
bunch of money on you know Outsourcing
or freelan aners or people to upload my
videos to my channel I need to
understand how the system works so that
I can hire the right people and build
the team correctly to begin with okay
and then number four is team so to break
that down so team comes before tactics
in my opinion because as a business
owner we are busy and we don't
necessarily need to understand every
little thing about every little tactic
that's why you need to rely on the right
team members so for example my YouTube
thumbnail designer I just knew that he
knew what he was doing so I put him on
my team let him run okay get out of
their way trust them that they
understand the system they understand
your they understand what you're trying
to do and then just get out of their way
and um let the team Implement your
tactics for you which is the next step I
know it's a range um of what it could
cost but I know people are curious if
they were Outsourcing a thumbnail maybe
you've worked with other people what
what does a thumbnail a good thumbnail
cost well I can only tell you what I pay
for thumbnails with my designer because
he's been with me you know since the
beginning well not the beginning of the
channel but as soon as I realized I
needed one yes and I pay like less than
$15 per
thumbnail that's that I I think that's
inspiring and if you're super strapped
than than you know canva and hustle
right but what you just said there I
want you to dive a little bit deeper in
this
because business owners Founders
entrepreneurs founder content creators
that have got these channels make should
they assess what their time is worth and
audit what their time is worth and how
good of a thumbnail could they even make
and how long will it take them to talk a
little bit about that because by
Outsourcing that one thing what have you
regained maybe in terms of even mindset
and focus and speed um 15 bucks one
thumbnail yeah and I order in a b batch
because I plan out my videos in a batch
and um so I order like four to eight at
a time depending on how far out I've
planned my videos so he actually even
gives me even a really great deal from
there because I order so many from him
and then he sends me he gives me free
thumbnails because I refer clients to
them and refer business to them so you
just have to find the right person for
you wow um but it do yeah it definitely
is a help I I kind of because I have a
visual background I'm I'm an artist too
in my hobby time
and I you know I could look at a
thumbnail and go I understand why that's
good and I can look at a thumbnail and
understand why it's not going to work
and so I at the beginning of the channel
before I had built out my system and my
team and everything was spending a bunch
of time in canva um you know try to
knock out the knockout thumbnails and
they were okay like even some of my top
performing videos have canva thumbnails
that I DIY and they still they do
awesome they like they did well um but
yeah you're right it was like I just had
to look at the what I want my hourly
rate to be and look at if I could just
pay a professional to do this because
they can do it faster and they can do it
better that is a better use of my time
and helps me maintain my hourly rate so
strong and I've learned personally too
delegation's been hard for me because
similar to you I have a background of
Photography so I could do my own
photography Photoshop so I could design
my own thumbnails and did for many years
um video editing
all of like the core competencies around
YouTube I skilled up little by little
and was at the center of all of that as
a solo YouTube Creator talking about
video affiliate marketing and all of
that but so it also made it difficult to
hand things off I had to also let go of
some Perfection I had to realize that
some of my quote unquote Perfection too
was still subjective like just because I
wanted a thumbnail to be a certain way
doesn't necessarily mean it would
perform better but prob the biggest
light ball moment for me was also just
decision fatigue it's it's one thing
like could I possibly get this task done
if I just hustle extra today and save
$15 or whatever but but what does it
cost in terms of the mental energy the
start stop of coming up with um of
getting into something new and then I
every I still do design thumbnails uh I
I actually use Cana even though I'm a
Photoshop person we have someone
full-time on the team that's a graphic
designer now and I do it one cuz I
always want to remind our community that
like everything is figureoutable and you
can do this and you can hustle and open
canva and figure every single thing out
no matter who you are and you could get
it done and you could put constraints on
like if I want to go live I'll use
streamyard and maybe get a thumbnail
done 10 minutes before it started just
something basic good enough and hit
record you know you got to just press
record uh but what I've realized is once
I start workshopping it I look at it a
little and I go oh I could probably
change a little more let me try this one
export it oh maybe I could tweak it a
little bit more and next thing you know
an hour has passed an hour and a half
has passed and as soon as you and that's
all energy it's decision fatigue it's
different things that's going to go from
something else which could be that next
level of your business thinking about
the next strategy thinking about the
next Innovative campaign thinking about
the next thing that could go produce
money and your hourly rate is much more
than $15 I would say everybody listening
to this needs to have the mindset that
their hourly rate is exponentially more
than that
early on especially scared money don't
make money sometimes it's about biting
the bullet getting uncomfortable letting
a go of perfectionism and delegating
something like that and I would argue
there's an exponential return on energy
and there's an exp ponential return on
mental focus or freeing up some of your
brain space so it's not even a $15
versus $100 an hour or whatever it's
even it's a whole different dimension of
you as an entrepreneur that can now
take new territory and ground and sees
New Opportunities once you start
delegating some of these things before
we go to the next one any thoughts on
this team conversation I would also say
that even thumbnails for me are a system
right so one of the hacks that I figured
out was um and this might especially
resonate with our women in the audience
where you feel like you need to do your
hair and your makeup and have a
different outfit on every thumbnail I
don't care about that I literally have a
closet in my office that has a red shirt
a green shirt a purple shirt a black
shirt and a blue shirt and I one day got
my ring light set up did my hair did my
makeup and knocked out a bunch of head
shot for the thumbnails with a variety
of different expressions and different
emotions upload them to my Google Drive
folder and then I share that with my
thumbnail designer so even for
thumbnails I'm not I'm not like taking a
photo every time I need a new thumbnail
and like you said about letting go of
perfection I don't care if the thumbnail
has a blue shirt and on the video I have
a green shirt I don't I don't really
care about that I'm just get it done get
it outsourced give my designer what he
needs in order to get the thumbnails
done um but that has become a little
system that might be helpful is just
knock out the head shots for your
thumbnails with a variety of different
Expressions different color shirts and
stuff so that when you do Outsource it
to your thumbnail designer you're ready
to go and you've got some assets and a
little system set up that makes it easy
so that was mindset strategy systems
team next is tactics tools and time
break it down well that's what we were
just kind of talking about is like so if
you're um you don't have to necessarily
know every little tactic that goes into
like creating great thumbnails or every
little tactic about how to optimize your
videos using vid IQ if you've got the
team members that know what they're
doing just trust them but make sure that
you're setting up the the that you're
providing your team members what they
need in order to get the Tactical stuff
you know done basically and what is the
best use of your time and um and what
tools do you need so do you need canva
or if you're another thing that not
necessarily even related to YouTube
thumbnails um but just something to
think about if you're Outsourcing your
marketing is what tools do you want to
use an example would be another graphic
design problem that you might have but
let's say you're creating a PDF lead
magnet for your website for your sales
funnel for your landing page and you're
going to Outsource that project to a
graphic designer and that graphic
designer Works in InDesign but you don't
know in design you work in canva making
sure that you're use if canva is the
tool that you want to use or maybe
you're even creating you hire a graphic
designer to create a thumbnail template
for you in your canva account be
thinking about what tools are you using
for your tax practical execution and
making sure that your team members are
using the tools that you're using o very
practical tip there and such one mistake
I made early on um was my approach to
editing as much of as of it as a skill
that it was was um I never did a very
good job of creating templates for
example just like saving a a project
that has like the theme music the intro
the this the that I would I would always
build it every single time your idea of
having like a designer give you a
template that you could plug into canva
so you that you could save time yep
that's a tactic those are tools that uh
could just shave so much those those
little things that compound obviously
especially as you multiply it by weeks
months and even years in your business
very good okay and then finally results
measure what matters my channel is small
but I have a sixf figure business off of
a small Channel because and TR my
Channel's not even monetized yet Sean
I'm like I'm I've that YouTube is
crushing me on the 4,000 hours like the
4,000 I'm like 2650 or something like
that my channel isn't monetized by
YouTube that is not the result that
matters to me what matters to me is is
the YouTube channel are the videos
putting people on my calendar that I can
talk to that is the number one thing
that I measure because that is the res I
know that if people are on my calendar
I'm going to get business so making sure
that you're measuring what matters and
not getting lost and um distracted by
maybe some of the vanity metrics that
make you feel bad about oh I see this
all the time in the v group people are
talking about how their videos aren't
blowing up or they're not going viral or
they're not monetized yet I'm like I
don't even care about that stuff I mean
I would love it if they would monetize
my Chanel if I could get my hours up
really fast but what really matters is
that YouTube has given me a business
model that it basically runs in my sleep
it's like a silent salesperson for me
putting bookings on my calendar people
to talk to from around the world who are
appreciative of my content I because I
speak with a lot of them by Zoom they
love my content they're they appreciate
what I do and they become happy clients
of mine to me that's what matters that
right there you make me want to jump out
of my chair run around the room and and
Shout because um you know and I think
what's interesting about the V Community
is we really do have two groups of um of
entrepreneurs and creators in there and
it's exactly that we have those that are
coming with the creater mindset and I
want every V student and every thick
media podcast listener to listen to Jen
and learn from Jen because the Creator
needs to learn from the business owner
to think different your Channel's not
even monetized but you've got a
six-figure business that is too that
right there is so shocking and almost
countercultural in the Creator economy
because what people focus on is YouTube
ad Revenue trying to get as many views
as possible trying to go viral and
oftentimes even consistent virality is
not sustainable but also it's not even
close to as profitable because cpms RPMs
go up and down it's hard it's also can
it could be very much the path to
burnout meanwhile you're on a different
path and of course what the entrepreneur
business owner can learn from is the
creators who learn how to get views
because then you start the funny thing I
think it was um I Heard Alex trosy talk
about this he was on Graham Stefan show
because Graham Stefan has gigantic
numbers and at the time I think had less
of a sophisticated business he's he's
tapped into a little bit of courses he
had a coffee for a while I'm I'm not
he's investing that now he's doing all
kinds of things to scale but I think at
the time it was kind of just like
Brand's ad revenue and he said something
because Alex was like the 100 million
dollar guy or whatever you know with all
these his approach to business and some
of the stuff he had done is uh Graham
was like uh man if I had your your
business Acumen um I'd probably be you
know a lot wealthier than I am right now
and then Alex said if I had your
audience Graham I'd be a billionaire
already
and uh because the business owner knows
is thinking about building that actual
backend the funnel what are the products
what are the services so anyways kind of
a a a Sidetrack there but that is our
ultimate dream inside of our V Community
is we're sort of living in this Creator
preneur environment where business
owners are becoming content creators and
content creators are becoming business
owners and that's why I'm so passionate
about this episode um ultimately
Jen uh we're going to link up your stuff
this has been incredibly helpful but I
want to really encourage think media
podcast listeners to pick up a copy of
Outsource your marketing and maybe
you're already in then that's you you
are already in but we're talking $13 is
what I see it for on Amazon right now
the ebooks like seven bucks it's 100
Pages it's easy to read a lot of
actionable stuff in there and I love
that but I I know that there's maybe
some listening that this particular
topic doesn't get you excited if you
know there's other things that you would
maybe gravitate towards some maybe it's
kind of like eating your vegetables if
you don't love vegetables I happen to
love vegetables so there's certain
things when it's like maybe deleg it may
me makes it a little uncomfortable too
it's kind of like oh it's kind of sounds
hard I might risk you know hiring
somebody and even though Jen's gonna
tell me how to do it ah you know maybe
just keep doing it the way I'm doing it
listen friends what you're doing is not
sustainable I see on Jen's website it
says delegate to accelerate we are
passionate about you not burning out and
even if you feel great right now you
need to make decisions today to set you
up for tomorrow the next year and five
years from now I'm so grateful for
decisions I made years ago in terms of
Delegation Outsourcing team and now with
a two and a half year old and a
nine-month-old it is delegate or die I
would probably be dead trying to run a
business trying to run the YouTube
channel trying to handle the kid life
and the business life Sony and I my wife
she's a CFO so it's a it's pretty heavy
load to run a multi-million dollar
company the books have gotten more
complex the team has gotten more complex
but we had to continue to skill up and
we had to there's certain books or
certain topics where it's like oh yeah
give me that and I sometimes avoid the
thing that I need and not just chasing
the thing that I want friend you need to
Outsource your marketing and begin even
taking baby steps and and Jen's giving
you the road map so you can check out
the show notes uh book is down there and
then there's also you have like a a free
resource that is just kind of supports
the book we'll make sure to put a link
in the show notes but but what is that
it's like a book resource that add some
additional content yeah there's it's a
couple different things there's some
checklists um some guides and then some
bonus videos that are not on my YouTube
channel that dive deeper into how to
delegate and actually there's a
checklist on that will help you figure
out what to delegate based on your zone
of Genius beautiful so we'll make sure
that you can see that whether you're on
audio or whether you're watching on
YouTube or anywhere else um you could
check out those free resources from Jen
as well the book on Amazon um and if you
want to check out video Rait Academy
because you're especially a business
owner entrepreneur and you know you need
to get serious about YouTube you can go
to VR podcast.com um and that's all down
there as well Jen as we land the plane
um give me one final word of
encouragement from a seasoned
entrepreneur like yourself you've done
many things including worked at Nasa uh
but you've you've run a photo studio you
have multiple businesses and what I know
is that I'm certain you also have some
some scars and some some hard seasons
and sometimes you wanted to quit
sometimes you were overwhelmed so
everybody listening to this if they take
the courageous lead Le of of launching a
channel launching a business trying
something new stretching beyond the
comfortable um there's a lot of fear
there's a lot of discouragement that can
come what comes to mind maybe of just a
few thoughts for the um listener that
maybe it's going through a hard time and
and maybe feeling like quitting or just
feeling a little discouraged what what
come what's what comes to mind when you
think about speaking a few words into
that individual you just can't quit if
you if you really want
to be an entrepreneur because you want
and I find that most entrepreneurs if
you're like me you want to be an
entrepreneur because you want freedom I
left my job at Nasa even though it was
very glamorous working with astronauts
super cool stuff but I left it because
the hours were long and the pay was
terrible and I wanted to have more
control and more freedom of over my life
and that is I think what a lot of
entrepreneurs have in common is freedom
to decide freedom to determine and
freedom to choose your own path and
determine your own worth making sure
that you're getting paid what you're
worth and that your business isn't you
know that your work isn't driving you
into the ground um with the hours but
the secret to my success has only been
consistency over time I just have not
quit and if one I had one business model
that shut down not from anything that I
did on my own but just because I had a
really terrible health problem I had
four organs removed in three surgeries
in two years and it brought me to my
knees literally I lost everything and I
had to start over again but I learned I
took the lessons that I learned up to
that point and use them to fuel me to
Build a Better Business and to build a
better life for myself and it has yes
Sean there have been days there have
been moments there still are but the
secret is to not quit just to let those
battles become the lessons and stay
consistent over time because you can do
it Jen so grateful for you your story is
powerful and uh thank you so much for
your encouragement today um check out
the show notes you can follow Jen on
Instagram as well at Jen D'Or RoR and uh
we'll have all of her links and
everything else think media podcast
thank you so much for being here
subscribe if you're not subscribed like
and share leave feedback depending on
where you're listening and we cannot
wait to connect with you in a future
episode